alarmierende zahlen kommen diese woche
aus paris wir sind zeuge der sechsten
großen massenaussterben es auf der erde
verursacht durch uns den menschen 85
prozent der feuchtgebiete sind zerstört
die hälfte der korallenriffe ebenso 9
prozent der nutztierarten sind
ausgestorben die biomasse der
wildlebenden tiere ist um 82 prozent
zurückgegangen 23 prozent der
landflächen auf der erde sind totes land
sie sind ökologisch herunter
gewirtschaftet und können nicht mehr
genutzt werden und so weiter und sofort
können wir die erde und vor allem uns
noch retten klicks zum science fiction
hier gibt's täglich faszinierend des
seins videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasst sie nicht herzlich
willkommen das hier hat mit panikmache
leider nichts zu tun das weltweit
höchste gremium von wissenschaftlern
lässt die alarmglocken schrillen
zitat die globale rate des artensterbens
ist mindestens um den faktor zehn bis
hundertmal höher als im durchschnitt der
vergangenen zehn millionen jahre und sie
wächst so der gerade veröffentlichte
bericht des biodiversitäts rates eps der
vereinten nationen wir stehen an der
schwelle zur vernichtung unseres
planeten und wir merken es ja auch
selbst verglichen mit früheren zeiten
gibt es viel weniger insekten was wir
sehen wenn wir mit dem auto schnell
fahren und kaum noch insekten die
windschutzscheibe verschmutzen
da haben wir ja auch schon darüber
berichtet und über diesen rückgang der
insekten dem wir selbst erleben gibt es
noch nicht mal studien über den wird in
dem bericht noch nicht mal eine
definitiven aussage getroffen anders ist
das bei vögeln amphibien und säugetieren
hier ist der rückgang beängstigend zitat
die gesundheit der ökosysteme von denen
wir und andere spezies abhängen
verschlechtert sich schneller als je
zuvor so der leiter des reports für
robert watson
so würden die grundlagen von einkommen
ernährungssicherheit gesundheit und
lebensqualität und zwar für uns menschen
beseitigt werden sprich die folge wird
das aussterben des menschen sein und die
hauptursache ist die landwirtschaft und
das ist wirklich paradox die man muss
sagen leider industrie die uns
eigentlich ernähren soll zerstört unsere
lebensgrundlagen die landwirtschaft
würde durch subventionen daran gehindert
lebensmittel umweltfreundlich zu
produzieren
so die wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftlerinnen
bundesumweltminister svenja schulze
nennt unter anderem die
eu-agrarsubventionen als grund
eigentlich ein gutes instrument um die
unabhängigkeit der eu von
lebensmittelimporten zu sichern
führen sie jetzt zur zerstörung der erde
zitat es kann keiner mehr sagen wir
haben es nicht gewusst dass sagt josef
settele vom helmholtz zentrum für
umweltforschung in leipzig und das ist
wirklich der punkt es handelt sich hier
um belastbare wissenschaftliche
erkenntnisse aus unmengen an studien es
ist wissenschaftlich erwiesen und
politiker und politikerinnen die diese
erkenntnisse nicht sofort in die tat
umsetzen sind tatsächlich eine gefahr
der bericht gibt jetzt zahlreiche
empfehlungen was getan werden müsse im
oktober 2020 findet der welt naturschutz
gipfel im chinesischen kunming stadt
dann müssen dort dringend
allerspätestens entscheidungen getroffen
werden es geht hier nicht um natur
liebhaberei oder sonstwas sondern um
unser überleben und auch wir können ganz
konkret etwas jetzt sofort ändern wir
können am 26 mai zur europawahl gehen
und zweitens genau die partei wählen die
die standpunkte vertritt die jetzt
wichtig sind und unser überleben sichert
wir sind diejenigen die entscheiden also
lasst es uns tun hashtag diesmal wähle
ich mehr dazu im video der tagesschau
hier wahlomat für die europawahl
da findet man die richtige partei mit
ein paar klicks also anklicken und
anschauen würde ich mal sagen wir sehen
uns am 26
im wahllokal bis dann bleibt dran